hello everyone today we'll go over the
step-by-step instructions to add an
additional key using this Pro key box
kit to begin you must have one working
key to add additional key this kit is
compatible with 2016 to 2018 Honda Pilot
I will list compatibility guide at the
end of this video this kit comes with
the aftermarket key the programmer tool
and the instruction manual if you have
your own unprogrammed key you can also
purchase the programmer tool separately
as an alternative option to save money
this tool will work on any aftermarket
or original key today we'll program the
aftermarket key with the kit once you
use this programmer tool it will lock to
your
Carin this means you can reuse it many
times in your vehicle but not in any
other vehicle so to begin the process
you need to connect the tool to the OBD
board once you connect it select add key
then press enter take all smart keys
outside the
vehicle then press enter
[Music]
place your working smart key inside the
vehicle press
enter press the push to start button
twice
[Music]
then press
enter the programmer will communicate
and configure the system of your
vehicle now take the smart key out of
your
[Music]
vehicle then press
enter bring in the new smart key to
start the programming
procedure press
enter the programmer will communicate to
your
vehicle when you hear the two beeping
sound switch the ignition off
then switch the ignition on by press the
push to start button
[Music]
twice you will hear to beeping
sound then switch the ignition off
again switch the ignition by press the
push to start button
twice you will hear to beeping
sound again then switch the ignition
off turn the ignition on by press the
push to start button
twice you will hear to beeping sound
then switch the ignition to
off again turn the ignition on by press
the push to start button twice for the
last time to complete the
[Music]
programming once here the beeping sound
indicating programming is
successful this means it is all done so
next unplug the tool and let's test the
key fob
[Music]
here we can see it's working and it's
all good to go repeat the steps if you
have more keys to
program hope you enjoyed the video thank
you for watching